[Música]
aquí comienza ellas hoy el programa
feminista de France 24 esta emisión la
vamos a dedicar a revisar a la situación
de las mujeres afganas y como su
desprotección puede llevar el país a
pique la decisión de los talibanes de
prohibir a sus ciudadanas que trabajen
además de ser violatoria de los Derechos
Humanos tiene grandes repercusiones en
la economía se estima que casi la mitad
de la población es femenina la ONU
advirtió además que estas medidas
represivas podrían significar una
reducción importante de ayuda económica
Andrés triviño nos cuenta Comencemos así
las mujeres y niñas afganas empeorarán
aún más la crisis económica del país así
lo advirtió recientemente un estudio de
la ONU en el cual asegura que la
producción económica de Afganistán se
desplomó un 20.7% con la retoma del
poder de los talibanes en agosto de 2021
presentamos los datos que tenemos que
muestra como la ausencia de mujeres en
la vida pública la educación y el
trabajo es perjudicial para el futuro de
la economía afgana recientemente el
talibán prohibió a las mujeres trabajar
para la uni una medida que le podría
costar al país la llegada de Nueva ayuda
económica en 2022 Afganistán recibió
3.200 millones de dólares en ayuda
internacional mediante la ONU la cual
podría ser reducida si el régimen
mantiene sus estrictas medidas las
mujeres representan casi la mitad de la
población afgana por lo que su lejanía
de la fuerza laboral podría afectar la
salida de la crisis económica de uno de
los países más pobres del mundo y son
las mujeres las más afectadas en una
sociedad profundamente conservadora y
patriarcal las autoridades pueden emitir
fuertes castigos y encuentran que una
mujer sale de su casa sin estar
totalmente cubierta con una burca una de
las primeras medidas del régimen a su
regreso viajar tampoco es una opción
para las afganas las mujeres que viajen
más de 72 kilómetros deben ir
acompañadas de un familiar varón cercano
pero tal vez una de las medidas que más
preocupan Es la falta de acceso a la
educación el régimen decidió que las
niñas mayores de 11 años no pueden ir a
la escuela convirtiéndose en el único
país en el mundo con una medida como
ésta den a raymi de 15 años lamenta que
no pudo volver a estudiar actualmente a
las niñas solo se les permite asistir a
escuelas islámicas donde en lugar de
matemáticas o literatura se enfocan en
aprender de memoria el Corán
es muy difícil porque mi hermano y yo
solíamos ir juntos a la escuela todos
los días pero ahora él va solo me veo
obligado a verlo ir a la escuela
mientras nosotras no podemos ir a
estudiar
a pesar de las restricciones y de las
fuertes consecuencias que pueden pagar
algunas mujeres se reúnen
clandestinamente hablar de sus derechos
una lucha que parece estar lejos de
llegar a su fin
la experta invitada para reflexionar
sobre estos actos de violación de
derechos humanos y en realidad de
misoginia es Pilares requena quien es
periodista quien es especialista en
relaciones internacionales y autora de
libros como Afganistán y la potencia
reticente Pilar Muchas gracias a usted
por estar en ellas hoy
Hola buenas tardes desde Madrid Buenos
días gracias a vosotros por contar
conmigo Bueno Pilar en menos de dos años
y esto Es evidente Afganistán retrocedió
violentamente a una realidad en la que
la mujer simplemente desaparece de la
vida pública ustedes cómo creen su
experiencia que la ciudadanas están
pagando esta nueva vida de desprotección
y esta pérdida evidente de derechos
ha habido como un cambio de todas formas
en estos últimos dos años algo que ya
advertimos los que conocemos bien
Afganistán hubo en un principio
analistas y también periodistas que de
alguna manera blanquearon a los
talibanes creyeron que había talibanes
Dos punto cero o talibanes que habían
cambiado y no era así es cierto que lo
que sí que han aprendido los talibanes
ha sido pues propaganda y ha sido
también de alguna manera cierta
diplomacia que es lo que han intentado
hacer en este año y medio vamos ya para
dos en agosto de su llegada al poder
porque lo que querían es parte de la
comunidad internacional
reconocimiento que todavía no se ha
producido que no se ha producido por
parte de la comunidad internacional y
sobre todo lo que necesitan es poner en
marcha un sistema económico porque la
situación realmente es terrible en
Afganistán yo estuve en el mes de
noviembre en kabul
mi primera vez después de la toma del
poder por los talibanes y la situación
era tremenda estuve justamente hasta
unos días antes de que prohibiesen
también a las mujeres ir a la
universidad cuando yo estuve las mujeres
bueno las niñas podían y pueden todavía
ir a enseñanza primaria No a secundaria
es decir no hay a lo que conocemos como
instituto o a partir de los digamos 10
11 años o nueve años dependiendo un poco
de las zonas y podían ir todavía a la
universidad ya como digo días después de
volver de Afganistán prohibieron también
el que fuesen a las universidades que
seguían abiertas y las facultades que se
hayan abiertas donde realmente estaban
completamente segregadas pero podían
recibir educación bueno Pilar
ciertamente todo esto está rodeado en el
gran contexto de la crisis de Afganistán
que es un país que desde hace décadas no
puede sostenerse por sí mismo que
depende de la ayuda internacional y que
tendría en algún momento que salir de la
crisis y poder sostenerse y funcionar de
una mejor manera pero uno ha sido
también tajante Y es que ningún país ha
dejado atrás a la mitad de su población
y de esta manera ha podido progresar
entonces las prohibiciones laborales de
las mujeres pues son definitivamente una
decisión errada no Solamente pensando en
derechos humanos sino pensando en la
propia Economía del país están
prescindiendo de profesionales y mujeres
valiosas que podrían estar aportándole
al pib más allá de ideologías Pues usted
como ve este proceso de crisis que
parece que de ser una es ser un espiral
que no tiene fin
tú lo has dicho es una espiral que no
que no tiene fin es que ese es el
problema los talibanes tienen un nivel
de misoginia difícil de entender es algo
que los enfrentes cara a cara y y veas
que realmente no han cambiado y que hay
un odio a las mujeres que que yo para mí
me resulta muy complicado
comprender cuando cuando hablo con ellos
y llego hablando desde hace muchos años
también en este último en esta última
ocasión cuando he estado entrevistado a
varios talibanes y de hecho tengo
incluso ahora mismo contacto con con un
viceministro talibán
realmente me resulta siempre imposible
de entender Ese odio que tienen a las
mujeres esa incapacidad de entender que
las mujeres son fundamentales que son el
50% de la población y como Les comento
más de uno no estaríais aquí en el mundo
si no existiésemos las mujeres con lo
cual no no pero hay que entender también
que muchos de estos talibanes han
llegado a las madrasas a estas escuelas
foránicas muy pequeños con cuatro o
cinco años y han dejado de tener
cualquier tipo de relación con madres
con hermanas con primas con mujeres en
general y que en la edad adulta no saben
tampoco Cómo
enfrentar o confrontar a las mujeres
porque las han cosificado les han
enseñado que no somos más que una cosa a
la que servimos para procrear que es la
única finalidad para ellos que tienen
las mujeres y es como dices es muy
complicado salir de esa espiral porque
el problema es que no es ni siquiera
solo una ideología es una misoginia
llevada a unos extremos inauditos y a
unos extremos incomprensibles en el
siglo XXI para la sociedad internacional
pero el gran problema es que nosotros
hemos dejado que estos talibanes
regresen regresen al poder porque
permitido también durante 20 años unos
gobiernos que estaban compuestos en
muchas en una parte importante por
criminales de guerra por corruptos en
una corrección en una corrupción de la
que en alguna manera también ha
participado la comunidad internacional
porque no puede haber corrupciones como
el tango si no hay dos
y todo eso lo hemos pagado caro y sobre
todo lo que se demostró en agosto del 21
es que Estados Unidos que era la
principal potencia que mantenía toda la
intervención internacional lo reconoció
el propio Estados Unidos y el propio
biden fuimos a vengarnos por el 11 de
septiembre y una vez que acabaron con
bilbaden y acabaron con la amenaza y al
qaeda y tienen también al parecer el
compromiso de los talibanes de que desde
Afganistán no se prepararán
no se prepararán atentados contra países
y tendrán bajo control a los diferentes
grupos terroristas que están ya dentro
de Afganistán pues parece suficiente
para Estados Unidos y una parte por no
decir la mayoría de la comunidad
internacional
con eso no con que mantengan estable el
país Aunque lo mantengan empobrecido con
una crisis humanitaria Terrible y con
una y con una falta de protección
absoluta de las de las mujeres que por
cierto hay que reconocer que siguen
siendo unas luchadoras
Cuando yo fui no iban con Borja el burta
no es obligatorio No es cierto los
talibanes no han dictaminado el vulca
obligatorio lo que han dictaminado es el
que ya y luego con una mascarilla que
muchas de ellas sin embargo no se ponen
en noviembre cuando yo estuve la mayor
parte de ellas lo que llevaban era un
pañuelo y muy pocas llevaban
por supuesto incluso vi menos burzas que
los que había visto antes de la llegada
de los talibanes estos tabul las
provincias es una situación
completamente distinta pero también lo
era y es mucho más terrible todavía pero
también lo era previamente hay escuelas
clandestinas hay clases online hay
mujeres que están arriesgando todo lo
posible y que están intentando mantener
lo que pueden y mantenerse de alguna
manera ocupadas porque como digo la
desesperación para todas estas mujeres
es total y absoluta durante 20 años
vieron una ventana de Esperanza sobre
todo en las ciudades ciudades que se ve
que se reducen a pabul a Gerard
y a la lavad como mucho pero y sobre
todo mayor el sabio y condus en esas
ciudades Estas mujeres empezaron a
ejercer sus profesiones a estudiar en la
universidad y a ver un futuro y esa
ventana se les cerró completo quedaba un
poquitín una una mini ventana abierta
que yo estoy convencida que los
talibanes solo la dejaron abierta para
conseguir ese reconocimiento y cuando
han visto que ese reconocimiento no
llega pues una de dos o ya han tomado la
decisión de ir al fondo de de sus de su
ideología y es prohibir a las mujeres
trabajar prohibir a las mujeres estudiar
o están todavía presionando más
esperando que la comunidad internacional
tenga una tenga una reacción que es el
reconocimiento y es el mantenimiento de
un sistema de un sistema económico
la verdad es que ninguna de las dos
opciones es buena no la perspectiva En
todo caso no es buena antes de que se
cumplan apenas dos años del regreso del
talibán Lamentablemente ya nos quedamos
sin tiempo Yo le agradezco mucho por
brindarnos su perspectiva Esta es una
entrevista que intentamos concretar
varias veces y al fin lo hemos logrado
Así que le deseo muchos éxitos y espero
podamos seguir contando con sus
opiniones informadas sobre este tema que
seguirá en la mesa de ella Soy Gracias
Pilar
seguro que seguirá Muchas gracias a
vosotros por desgracia va a seguir
durante mucho tiempo y a nuestros
televidentes Gracias por vernos una vez
más nos vemos Próximamente en ellas hoy
en France 24
[Música]